les hemos contado que las películas de
hispanoamérica están ausentes de la
competencia oficial de este festival de
cannes pero no así de las secciones
paralelas y ayer fue el estreno de
libertad de la española clara roquet en
la semana de la crítica una película que
habla sobre la crisis de adolescencia de
una chica que está marcada por el
alzheimer de su abuela por la inminente
separación de sus padres y por la
llegada de unas chicas desde colombia
que es la hija de la empleada doméstica
que trabaja en su casa la película fue
recibida con aplausos de pie en ausencia
de la directora que se encuentra en
barcelona haciendo una cuarentena por
kobe 19 sino hoy sigue la competencia
oficial habrá dos alfombras rojas una
para la fractura de catering ok sheen y
una de las siete películas francesas en
competencia por la palma de oro y sino
la esperada y polémica
benedetta del holandés paul verhoeven
una película que narra la historia de
una monja lesbiana en el siglo 17 en
italia las organizaciones feministas
critican este director dicen que
maltrata la imagen de la mujer algo que
ha sido desmentido por la protagonista
del filme
el ga virginie efira